peu
[Musique]
jamais on n'avait vu autant de monde à
londres c'était le 2 juin 1953 et là
dans toute la ville dans les avenues
dans les jardins sur les boulevards sur
les trottoirs sur les chaussées il y
avait des millions des millions et des
millions de gens et même la ville on
avait l'impression qu'elle avait changé
les ruines qui était resté si longtemps
témoignage de la guerre avait disparu
depuis un an l'avait construit trois
cent mille logements neufs et les vieux
immeubles on les avait ravalé on les
avait repeint les parcs les parcs
transformer en potager pendant la guerre
était redevenu des jardins avec des
fleurs des plantes des dessins de toutes
sortes et dans la rue c'était d'autres
anglais que l'on voyait des femmes qui
retrouvait l'élégance des hommes qui
avaient ressorti de la naphtaline
le célèbre chapeau melon et pourquoi
tous ces gens-là était-il à londres le 2
juin 1953 et bien parce que c'était la
coronation le couronnement de la reine
elizabeth 2
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
et même ce couronnement devait marquer
une date supplémentaire dans l'histoire
ouvrez n'importe quelle histoire de la
télévision et vous verrez que les
historiens date de ce jour là le
véritable essor de la télévision
française puisqu'on a télévisée le
couronnement de là
[Musique]
alors au milieu de ces images de ce flou
d'image archaïque touchante mais
fascinante
comment ne pas s'attarder à celle ci ce
vieil homme
ce vieil homme vêtu d'un costume étrange
incroyable qui est tout simplement celui
de chevalier de la jarretière et ce
vieil homme a reçu cet ordre créé 14e
siècle des mains de la reine quelques
jours auparavant seulement et elle lui a
dit agenouillé vous monsieur tchatche et
il a obéi
on a donné à la reine une épée qu'elle a
posée sur l'épaule de châtier elle lui a
dit loew et vous seuls whist et où il
était désormais l'un des 25 anglais pas
un de plus chevalier de la jarretière
couronnement d'une jeune reine mais
apothéose d'un homme dette apothéose
d'un homme qui pourtant aura bientôt 80
ans d'un homme qui bientôt va quitter
l'arène politique et qui en la quittant
fatalement repensera à cette vie unique
cette vie sans exemple comme personne
n'en a vécu dans notre siècle
[Musique]
alors oui cette image maintenant que
nous voyons le château de blaine
c'est là qu'il est né et comment se dire
qu'il a vu à couronnement télévisée
qu'il a été le contemporain de toutes
les inventions qu'il a pu entendre les
disques des beatles et que pourtant il
est né dans un palais comme celui là qui
nous semblent hors du temps et il est
vraiment hors du temps parce que ce sont
les anglais au xviie siècle qu'ils ont
offert un général qui s'appelait turtur
mais qui a été le premier duc de
marlborough pourquoi lui attend offert
ce palais bien parce que tout simplement
ils avaient vaincu louis xiv ce qu'il
était quand même pas mal en 1874 date de
l'anel winston churchill et bien c'était
le 7e duc de marlborough qu'habiter blé
nain
[Musique]
savez vous que il fallait plus de cinq
ans de vallée pour assurer le service du
château sans compter des dizaines et des
dizaines d'autres domestique
alors l'histoire commence à causse vous
savez il ya des rites en grande bretagne
et c'est normal on n'imagine pas
l'angleterre sans ses traditions
sancerry tilly at-elle courses de
chevaux chaque année à telle date où il
faut aller il y à l'affrontement
traditionnel des équipes d'oxford et de
cambridge et il ya les régates de corse
est cette année l'un l'un des fils cadet
du septième double de mahmoud s'appelait
randolph tchatche il avait 24 ans était
allé voir les régates et la même année
une américaine qui habitait à paris
mais si rome avait voulu montrer les
régates de corse à sa fille jenny qu'il
n'y avait eu un bal après les régates et
le jeune randolph avait rencontré la
jeune jane savez nous sommes dans l'ère
victorienne à cette époque les mariages
sont toujours arrangé les familles se
réunissent
on prépare le mariage on dit et bien
est-ce que vous pensez que ma plus jeune
fille conviendrait à votre plus jeune
fils et cetera et cetera on pèse les
dots et bien pas du tout ils tombent
amoureux l'un de l'autre et c'est bien
sympathique et trois jours après sans
avoir rien demandé à personne ils sont
fiancés et il va falloir que les
familles acceptent
[Musique]
à l'automne suivant le septième duc de
marlborough donne un bal à blaine
vous imaginez ce que pouvait être ces
années là un bal à blaine toute
l'aristocratie est venu c'est splendide
les orchestres les chandelles tout y est
c'est super et parmi les danseurs et
bien il y à la jeune lady chat chez la
femme de randolph l'américaine tout
jeune a 20 ans et elle dansait on trouve
que c'est quand même un peu imprudent
parce qu'elle est enceinte de sept mois
mais pas du tout elle se porte très bien
elle danse mais tout à coup elle pallie
et dit à son danseur excusez moi je ne
me sens pas très bien je crois que je
vais accoucher à mandelieu d'amal savait
un certain effet alors on s'empresse on
veut la conduire dans sa chambre mais
blenheim c'est tellement grand pour
arriver dans la chambre il faut marcher
20 minutes
alors elle s'arrête dit non non non je
ne peux pas aller plus loin et sur ce
lit aux quelques minutes elle accouche
d'un gros garçon à sept mois c'est pas
mal d'être un gros berson ce prématurée
est en parfaite santé et il est roux
voilà que winston churchill car celui
bien sûr aux arrêts compris vient de
faire une entrée dans la vie
particulièrement remarque alors son
enfance normalement l'impression que
toutes les fées se sont penchées sur son
berceau l'argent la gloire le rang mais
pas sur ses passions bien sûr il ira à
dublin avec son grand père parce que le
roi nommé le duc de marlborough vice roi
d'irlande ce qui n'est pas une sinécure
ou savait parce que les hollandais
n'aime pas beaucoup les anglais ses
parents il n'aura pas beaucoup de
souvenirs parce que randolph churchill
s'est jetée dans la politique il
deviendra même chancelier de l'échiquier
c'est un important personnage il n'est
jamais à la maison et le petit winston
ne voit jamais son papa sa maman sa
jolie maman et bien elle vient tous les
soirs à la nurserie cinq minutes avant
le l'idée
et le petit garçon a droit à cinq
minutes par jour puis l'heure viendra où
il faudra entrer à l'école il entra
s'étant lui a coupé les cheveux
il est établi en fit jusque là et il
entre dans un bagne vous avez lu dickens
vous vous souvenez des cannes c'est bien
ça existe toujours
à cette époque là à la fin du 19e siècle
et dans ses souvenirs d'enfance il
dépeindra les horreurs d'antan n'accable
les enfants de 7 ans on les bat mais
attention les ordres sont donnés de
battre avec des verges jusqu'à ce que le
sens du dos ou des fesses j'haïs c'est
purement et simplement du sadisme
alors il souffre beaucoup c'est un petit
garçon sensible il supplie ses parents
de l'ôter de cette école il est reste
quand même 2 en poule mais dans une
autre école et leur là il sombre
totalement dans une véritable à pattes
parce que on ennuie plus est dans son
coin tout le monde dîne pas bien
intelligent ce pauvre winston en fait
ils s'intéressent pas à grand chose
il est là il regarde il écoute il est
tranquille morne et il arrivera dans le
même état à l'université aarau et lors
l'homme à l'époque les études c'est
surtout le latin et le grec bay ne
s'intéresse pas du tout aux latins il ne
s'intéresse pas du tout au gré c'est pas
très grave à cette époque pour un
gentleman
parce que mon dieu on pense qu'un
internement n'a pas tellement besoin de
faire des études classiques mais ce qui
est très grave
alors là c'est un crime il ne
s'intéresse pas non plus au cricket
comment le t-shirt chine ne s'intéresse
pas aux quatre anneaux s'est terré spa
alors là vraiment le méprise il était nu
en dehors on dit qu'est ce que c'est que
ce garçon c'est un sauvage et les mal
élevés bon alors il est bon nageur pour
son malheur parce que ça c'est un sport
vulgaire alors ça n'intéresse personne
alors on n'aime pas beaucoup tu as chill
winston churchill à l'université et les
parents se demandent ce qu'ils vont
faire de lui et pénétrant par hasard
dans sa chambre en dehors
churchill le pet voit que le petit
garçon a sur sa table
des soldats plomb dirais que nous avons
tous eu des soldats plomb bah oui mais
le père regarde ça c'est la révélation
c'est l'oeuf de christophe colomb il dit
mon fils c'est évident a une vocation
militaire alors là c'est le miracle
lui qui ne s'est jamais intéressé à rien
tout à coup il se passionne pour les
études que l'on donne à l'école de saint
jean est
il est tellement à son affaire que deux
ans plus tard il sort 8e sur 150
ce qui n'est pas mal il est sous
lieutenant dans un régiment de heath
alors ce qu'il voudrait mine maintenant
c'est faire la guerre ce qui est assez
normal parce que finalement qu'est ce
qu'on apprend dans une école militaire
c'est à faire la guerre il est là et il
se dit mais quand fera t-on la guerre
malheureusement ou heureusement ça
dépend du point de vue auquel on se
place il n'y a aucune guerre dans le
monde
en ce qui concerne l' empire brit air ce
qui s'étend sur cet immense empire c'est
ce qu'on appelle la pax britannique à la
paix britannique
alors pas de guerre et s'ennuie beaucoup
winston churchill alors il y les
journaux cherchent et s'aperçoit qu'il
ya comme une guerre mais elle n'est pas
dans l' empire britannique elle est à
cuba parce que cuba est une possession
espagnole sadate de christophe colomb et
les cubains sont fini par se dire mais
pourquoi dépendons nous des espagnols
pourquoi ne serions nous pas des gens
indépendants ils font la guerre contre
les espagnols alors à cette époque là un
officier un jeune officier surtout si
les gentlemans à cinq mois de congé par
an ce qui n'est pas mal
le congé arrive et bien tout simplement
wiston churchill prend le bateau pour
cuba puisqu'il ya une game ailleurs et
il va combattre dans les rangs espagnols
il n'est pas particulièrement partisans
de la dépendance des peuples turcs il il
ne sera jamais d'ailleurs il faut le
voir tel qu'il est complètement imprégné
de l'idéal de vie
et du style victorien et même il va
charger les insurgés vêtu de son costume
de star britannique avoué que c'était
des temps singulièrement différents des
nôtres
et puis il va rentrer en angleterre pour
apprendre au bonheur que son régiment
est désigné pour les uns
[Musique]
tout jeune officier rêve des ânes le
voilà aux seins dans le sud des indes la
garnison à 917 m d'altitude un air frais
un climat merveilleux le paradis sur
terre un sous-lieutenant dispose une
maison avec un maître d'hôtel plusieurs
domestique et une équipe personnelle le
pôle ans ce sont de véritables potentats
que les officiers britanniques aux uns
les autres sont ravissants satisfont à
lui parce que il voudrait bien faire la
guerre l'inde est pacifique cette époque
pas de guerre alors en lisant les
journaux il s'aperçoit que même qu'il ya
une guerre là bas tout en haut au nord
au nord ouest à la frontière afghane
ringer givet ben non il n'y va pas parce
que le son régiment de 800 n'y va pas on
ne peut pas y aller mais heureusement
arrive le congé annuel et il va de
nouveau passer son congé là-bas à faire
la guerre dans le nord avec une
différence il s'est fait désigner comme
correspondant de guerre par un journal
local le pionnier est cependant qu'il
participe au combat vous pensez bien que
arrivé là bas tu ne veux pas simplement
se contenter d'aller voir les combats et
d'en prendre des notes pour le câble et
le soir un télégramme à son journal il
est là il se barre peut pas faire
autrement il s'appellerait pas churchill
alors ils envoient des articles
tellement vivant sur cette campagne
qu'on lit le pionnier à lons et que le
daily telegraph va reproduire les
articles du pioneer et on les lire avec
beaucoup de sympathie à londres et même
quand il sera rentré il réunira ses
articles dans un volume qui aura un joli
succès qui remportera joli succès à
londres et même le prince de galles lui
enverra des félicitations
mais il n'ya plus de guerre pour le
moment alors que va-t-il faire mal il va
démissionner de l'armée
le voilà à l'ombre il est suivi il a
décidé de vivre de sa plume or c'est le
temps où se prépare sur le nil
une expédition anglo égyptienne qui doit
venger la mort du général ghori
en ces temps là orange la mort d'un
génère alors chelsea dimanche il faut qu
ils tâchent de ce fait envoyé comme
militaire la mort lui répond vous avait
démissionné vous n'aviez qu'à pas
démissionné finalement il fait des pieds
et des mains réussi à être envoyés en
volontaire et on lui dit mais c'est vous
qui paierez le voyage il paie le voyage
et on le dit si vous êtes blessé vous
n'aurez pas de pension tac et il rejoint
sur la seconde cataractes du deal
le 21e lanciers auquel il va être
affecté
et c'est même lui qui sera envoyé en
reconnaissance lorsqu on signalera
devant les troupes anglaises un fort
contingent d'ennemis soudanais et il
vient faire son rapport au général
kitchen est en général il est à la obame
aux soixante mille derviches qui nous
attendent
fortement armés les derviches on croit
rêver déjà et c'est lui churchill avec
le 21e lanciers qui va affronter le
premier seder vif qui n'y sont décidés à
se défendre avec une énergie farouche et
dans cette charge qui est peut être la
dernière charge historique d'autrefois
avant l'invention la mitrailleuse et
bien ils vont perdre le tiers de
l'effectif et à la fin de la journée il
y aura vingt mille cadavres de soude
année sur le sol ce qui montre la
violence de la bataille est c'est fait
le soudan est devenu anglais et quand il
rentre en grande bretagne et bien il
s'aperçoit que ces articles
et bien tout le monde les a lus il est
devenu une manière de héros national
et quand il réunit ses articles en
livres avec un très joli titre la guerre
au long du fleuve le fleuve c'est le nil
et bien c'est un best-seller
considérable et il devient riche et will
devient riche par sa littérature et il
ira faire des conférences à travers
toute la grande bretagne on
l'accueillera commun triomphateur mêmes
on engagera pour une autre tournée de
conférences aux états unis que l'on perd
à 10000 livres sterling une fortune mais
déjà ils cherchent une autre guerre
turcs il a besoin d'une guerre alors il
en trouve une là bas en afrique australe
il s'est présenté au siège d'un journal
de long le morning post
et il a demandé à être envoyé comme
correspondant de guerre cette guerre qui
commence en afrique du sud pourquoi une
gaie et bien parce qu'il y a là deux
vieux états les états bourg formé de
l'ancien colon landais avaient quelques
français aussi venu là dès le xviie
siècle l'état du transvaal l'oranje et
bien ces états sont en butte à des
incursions de colons britanniques qui
sont plus au sud on l'a découvert de
l'or en afrique du sud des aventuriers
sont venus de partout surtout
d'angleterre comme eux n'ont pas trouvé
d'or et bien alors ils se vengent sur
les beaux yeux
[Applaudissements]
alors le bourg adressé une protestation
à londres disant faites cesser ses
incursions et londres répond par une
déclaration de guerre
[Musique]
alors que s'achève où l'immense règne de
la reine victoria qui par la grâce de
disraeli et non seulement reine
d'angleterre mais impératrice des indes
et bien les anglais vivent dans une
sorte d'ivresse de leur toute puissance
c'est la perspective impérial car si
bien chanté kipling alors pourquoi pas
il y à deux et à bourg qu'est ce que ça
peut faire on va les absorber
[Musique]
alors évidemment à washington à paris ou
à berlin on n'est pas très contents
parle de guerre d'agression ce qui est
parfaitement vrai mais les anglais ont
une parfaite bonne conscience et
churchill quand il sent pas en parfaite
bonne conscience parce qu'il estime que
les anglais apporte la civilisation à
ces paysans et il sait que de toute
façon les paysans vont être battus en
quelques jours ils n'ont pas d'armement
pas d'uniforme pas de commandement et il
a très peur il s'est dit mais quand mon
bateau arrivera au cap
les voyages sont très longs à cette
époque là la guerre sera finie et bien
pas du tout quand ils arrivent au cap il
apprend que les fameux paysans battu à
plate couture l'armée anglaise les
habits rouges ont cédé devant les bourre
avec leurs vieux fusil qui datent de 50
ou 100 ans
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
et même ils ont envahi le natal et même
ils assiègent la forteresse la plus
importante
les 10 messe une forteresse assiégée sur
tille dit j'y vais vous ne pourrez pas y
aller le pays est infestée de bourg et
bien j'irai par le train blindé parce
que on envoie un train blindé
ravitailler les 10me ce jeu montré dans
le train blindé l'iman
ce qui n'a pas prévu c'est que les
bourgs qui utilisent tous les incidents
leur faveur et tous les accidents de
terrain et toutes les occasions ont
placé une bombe sur la voie ferrée et
que tant la locomotive arrive sur cette
banque
elle explose la locomotive explosent
également le train déraille les bourgs
arrivent de partout tire tire au canon
sur le train il ya des morts des blessés
churchill arrive à courir vers une
rivière qui l'a aperçu là ils sont dans
la rivière ils espèrent la traversée à
la nage
bon nageur lorsqu'un officier bout un
cavalier le vise avec son fusil
je vous tiens à ma merci rendez-vous il
n'a même pas de revolver il a laissé
dans le train du ceran et bien cet
officier s'appelle louis botha qui
pourrait savoir que plus tard il sera le
général soeur louise botha et premier
ministre guy dominion britannique
d'afrique du sud est l'un des grands
amis de turquie puis les prisonniers
churchill on le jette dans une prison de
pretoria et des milliers ils pensent à
s'évader
il prépare un plan il faut passer dans
les latrines s'y faire enfermer quand on
ne s'occupe plus de lui en sortie
franchir le mur courir à la gare ce
qu'il fait il y arrive il monte dans un
train de marchandises du parc vers une
destination qu'il ne connaît pas il est
en plein payer
planigo et le train roule jour la nuit
le jury ne sait toujours pas où il est
normalement ce train s'en va au
mozambique en territoire portugais et le
voilà qui roulent encore le jour la nuit
le nuit la rue et enfin matin il est
bourde force par les interstices du
wagon il voit le panneau de la gare où
se trouve c'est un nom portugais et l'on
regarde les uniformes des employés de la
gare ce sont des uniformes portugais
alors là rien
il est fou de joie il pourrait se
reposer dans cet état neutre doit pas du
tout ils sont dans un bateau parce qu'il
veut retourner se battre au cap
et là il se lance toujours journalistes
il envoie toujours ses articles à
londres mais toujours combattants parce
qu'il est entré dans une unité
irrégulier il un grand chapeau à larges
bords avec des plumes de coq et ils
chargeaient une se bat tous ses amis ou
presque trouvent la mort à côté de lui
son frère john qui l'a rejoint et
grièvement blessé b lui passent à
travers les balles ça c'est
extraordinaire
et même il fait des choses insensées il
prend le pari de traverser la capitale
bourg la capitale ennemie à bicyclette
en plein jour il le fait il n'est pas
reconnu il n'est pas prêt il indien ça
c'est chuck
mais évidemment les victoires provisoire
des bourgs ne peuvent pas durer
éternellement de plein bateau le renfort
arrive avec un matériel mans ce terrible
et peu à peu les bourgs comprennent
qu'ils ont perdu la guerre
[Musique]
alors puisqu'il n'y a plus guère ou
presque bien quartier leur part pour
loin et quand ils arrivent à lons il se
rend compte qu'il est devenu une manière
de héros national
et oui on l'avait un peu parler de lui
après l'histoire de l'egypte mais ces
articles ont été reproduits par tous les
journaux l'histoire de son évasion il
n'y a pas un anglais qu'ils la
connaissent
et pourquoi bien parce que les anglais
avaient été humiliés
c'était la première grande atteinte à
leur fierté alors orgueil insulaire
depuis napoléon et la voilà qu'un un
anonyme
ce jeune churchill comme disent ce jeune
monsieur churchill et bien il les
vengent parce qu'il ridiculise les
bourgs en s'évadant et en les affrontant
comme il le fait avec tant de panache et
d' allure alors c'est un héros national
ont réuni ses articles ont les publient
c'est un best-seller ils gagnent
énormément d'argent et puis on engage
pour des conférences une tournée de
conférences il gagne encore plus
d'argent
et puis même les américains langage pour
raconter cette aventure en afrique
australe
dix mille livres pour sa tournée de
conférences américaine vous allez me
dire mais enfin est ce qu'il a vraiment
besoin d'argent mais oui il a besoin
l'oeuvre parce que à cette époque là
dans une famille comme les marmots c'est
le droit d'aînesse qui s'exerce la
fortune les domaines ce sera pour le
fils aîné winston churchill n'est même
pas un cadet c'est le fils d'un cadet
son père n'a rien laissé et sa mère
s'est remariée avec un officier sans
fortune c'est maintenant louis winston
qui est sa mère et une led avec ce qu'il
gagne par sa plus éparses et conférences
alors justement ce sont les élections et
il est élu triomphalement le voit la
députée à la chambre des communes la vie
d' aventure de winston churchill
s'achève enfin à peu près parce qu'il
aura encore des as
en dur ce qui commence c'est sa grande
carrière politique
sa grande carrière parlementaire alors
je ne vais pas naturellement évoquer
toutes les étapes de cette carrière
parce que ce serait raconter toute
l'histoire britannique pendant un demi
siècle
mais si vous voulez nous allons nous
arrêter de temps en temps alors je le
vois là en plein hiver la chambre de
communes ce grand rectangle
sous ce toit néo gothique sous ce
plafond néogothique la chambre des
communes est en séance et on discute de
la drees roi car la reine victoria
yann mûri son fils est monté sur le
trône sous le nom de edouard 7
on doit lui présenter une adresse et on
discute beaucoup de l'afrique du sud
parce que bien entendu c'est le sujet à
la mode on trouve que la guerre a été
mal conduite c'est qu'il ait fallu tant
de temps pour gagner c'est insupportable
et puis aussi à tous même des choses
désagréables
[Musique]
pour gagner justement là employés des
procédés qu'on ne peut pas facilement
louer
on a fait brûler des villages entiers on
a arrêté les populations civiles
hommes femmes enfants on les achetait
dans des camps que l'on appelle des
camps de reconcentration senti son que
qui nous dit quelque chose d'autre hélas
ces populations ne sont mal nourris
elles ne sont pas soignées n'y a pas de
corps médical il ya beaucoup de
mortalité savez vous que les enfants qui
ont accompagné leurs parents dans ces
camps mourront à raison de 50 pour cent
cinquante pour cent des enfants qui
meurent alors ça on le dit partout et
l'angleterre connaît une impopularité
prodigieux c'est le temps où les
français vont se battre aux côtés des
bourgs et des gens de tous les pays
alors ça on le sait et ça gêne pas mal
le monde et le leader libéral log
georges un gallois pinasse est en train
de le dire là et voilà que sur les bancs
un jeune député demande la parole et on
dit tiens qui est-ce qui est ce qui s
est passé le jeune winston churchill le
fils de randolph
oui le fils de 9 il bat il a écrit son
discours il a appris par coeur il parle
avec un accent un peu nasillard et puis
il a du mal à prononcer le fc il parle
comme ça il dévoila ne vais vous parler
de l'afrique du sud évidemment c'est un
peu gênant pour un orateur mais c'est
original et on écoute ça aide à faire
entendre
l'orateur est ce qu'il dit il dit il
faut gagner la guerre elle est presque
gagnée il faut la gagner mais une fois
qu'on l'aura gagnée
il ne faut pas traiter les bourgs comme
des vaincus il faut les traiter comme
des gens qui méritent le respect et moi
qui vous parle qui les ai combattu
je les respecte
et ça fait un certain effet et quand il
sera si on l'applaudît et john
chamberlain vieux routier de la chambre
des communes dit peut-être bien qu'il
suivra une carrière semblable à celle de
son père alors ce qui est curieux c'est
qu'il est assis dans les rangs
conservateurs et que presque toujours
quand il ya un débat ils critiquent son
propre parti ces arguments sont presque
toujours ceux des adversaires des
conservateurs c'est à dire les libéraux
à ce moment là le parti travailliste
labour party est encore dans les limbes
mialhe représente pas grand chose alors
les gens qui sont plutôt à gauche sont
les libéraux et ceux qui sont à droite
sont les conservateurs je parle dans le
contexte français gauche et droit qui
n'est pas le même en angleterre ans est
curieux que le conservateur du recul
justement épouser les idées des libéraux
et les épouses parce qu'en fait ce sont
ses idées et se seront tellement ses
idées qu'un beau jour il va changer de
camp et il va s'inscrire au parent qui
libère nous sommes dans un pays de
tradition
l'angleterre c'est la tradi alors on
n'aime pas du tout ça en angleterre on
n'aime pas quelqu'un qui change de parc
et d'un seul coup churchill sera
extrêmement impopulaire on l'appellera
le renégat et quand il arrivera quelque
part y aura toujours quelqu'un qui fera
le geste de retourner sa veste
ces pannes situation common et puis lors
de nouvelles élections quand ce sont les
libéraux qui l'emportent
et quand dans un gouvernement libéral il
devient pour la première fois ministre
sous secrétaire d'état aux colonies ses
anciens amis conservateurs c'est disent
ah bah voilà
il a flairé le vent c'est un arriviste
c'est un ambitieux il s'est dit les
libéraux vont l'emporter
et moi je vais dans le camp de ceux qui
vont gagner alors on le méprise encore
un peu plus c'est pourtant l'époque où
il a rencontré au cours d'une campagne
électorale
la fille d'un colonel le colonel osier
elle s'appelle clément times
elle est charmante il tombe amoureux
d'elle il les pousse les rosiers n'ont
pas d'argent tant pis winston churchill
n'est pas homme à courir les dots il
sait qu'il doit décidément entretenir sa
famille avec l'argent qu'il gagnera sans
lui déplaît pas du tout et la dernière
phase de ses souvenirs de jeunesse
mérite d'être citée elle est très
laconique je me marier et dès ce moment
je suis toujours heureux c'est charmant
non elle lui donnera plusieurs enfants
[Musique]
et ce sera une famille très unie que la
famille cartier alors il sera ministre
du commerce et on oublie toujours que
c'est lui qui va faire passer des lois
importantes
la loi sur la sécurité sociale
c'est lui l'assurance maladie c'est lui
alors vers il est populaire surtout dans
les milieux ouvriers paysans dans le
prolétariat faut dire qu'il fait tout
pour cultiver cette popularité
ça n'est pas quelqu'un qui est tombé de
la dernière pluie
winston churchill par exemple il écrit
toujours ses discours avant de les
prononcer il les fait recopie à
plusieurs exemplaires et les envois la
veille du jour où il valait prononcé aux
journaux pour être sûr que les journaux
les aurons et pourront les publier et
les rédacteurs en chef qui reçoivent les
discours pas encore prononcé verrons
après certains paragraphes cette formule
applaudissements prolongés faut bien
préparer tout même sa propre gloire
c'est un metteur en scène
churchill mais voilà lé l'acteur qu'il
met en scène est unique et c'est
lui-même un jour il se trompe dans un
vestiaire et prend un chapeau qui n'est
pas le sien jappo trop petit et sa
personne le lendemain ya plusieurs
caricature qui le montrent avec ce
chapeau trop petit c'est dix bonnes
idées pour que ma silhouette soit
populariser et ils achètent délibérément
des chapeaux trop petit
et puis il aura toujours la même cravate
à pois le même le papillon à pois et
puis lorsqu'il avancera un âge on le
verra toujours avec ce cigare sa musique
a même devenu très vieux il fumera à
peine mais il aura toujours un cigare ça
fait partie de sa personnalité
puis souvenez vous alors là dans la
grande époque de sa vie v ça c'est
churchill
c'est excellent alors il est populaire
mais pour son malheur on le nomme
ministre de l'intérieur c'est un cadeau
empoisonné en général le ministère de
l'intérieur
parce qu'il ya justement des grèves des
grandes grèves de cheminots de docker
2001 et c'est le ministre de l'intérieur
qui doit les réprimer et il les
répriment alors il envoie l'armée il dit
à l'armée vous ne les tuez pas mais tout
le reste est permis alors on frappe on
va vous fait pas vous faire un dessin
c'est une chose qu'on voit encore
aujourd'hui un télévision alors d'un
seul coup sa popularité tombe à zéro
heureusement heureusement on va le
nommer premier lord de l'amirauté
premier lord de l'amirauté cela veut
dire ministre de la marque et disons
qu'il est fait pour ce parce qu'il n'est
pas marin d'origine c'est un hussard est
sorti de l'école militaire pas de
l'école la mère mais il est anglais et
il est même la quintessence d'un anglais
et l'anglais s'identifie toujours
totalement à la marée alors cette marine
il va l'aimer comme sa chose et il va
lui donner un élan prodigieux parce que
c'est la montée des périls dans ce temps
là c'est en 1911 c'est le temps où la
marine allemande devient redoutable
c'est le temps où l'on peut déjà
connaître les ambitions allemandes
c'est le temps où l'allemagne
[Musique]
et il faut que la marine anglaise soit
prête pour le jour j
et quand la guerre éclate août 1914 elle
est prête et c'est grâce à tchatcher que
le corps expéditionnaire britannique
pourra passer en flandre tutsis à la
barbe des allemands que la marine
anglaise tiendra totalement en respect
et puis churchill n'est pas un ministre
qui reste dans son cabinet le voilà à
dunkerque
lle l'animent la défense il est à anvers
ils s'enferment dans anvers pour animer
la résistance et puis la guerre s'enlise
après la victoire de la main face à face
dans leurs tranchées les ennemis des
attaques sporadiques qui coûte beaucoup
monde mais on se dit mais qui
l'emportera c'est alors que churchill à
une idée est une idée de visionnaire qui
est une idée qui lui ressemble il dit
bien oui nous sommes là dans la terre
dans la boue des tranchées
ça peut durer éternellement il faut
vaincre ailleurs la turquie est l'alliée
l'allemagne et l'autriche
eh bien nous allons aller vaincre la
turquie chez elle à constantinople on
lui répond mais alors à constantinople
il faut leur ai passé les dardanelles
c'est impossible dit comment impossible
la flotte anglaise
la flotte française ne pourrait pas
forcer le détroit des dardanelles et il
plaide si bien qu'on l'ait coûte à
londres et qu'on écoute à paris
l'expédition des dardanelles est
ordonnée vous le savez ce sera un échec
et cet échec on veut le faire payer très
cher as tu retires
c'est lui le responsable on le montre du
doigt il à vous dire mais enfin il ya eu
des erreurs et c'est vrai qu'il ya eu
des erreurs on pouvait réussir mais on a
été trop timoré au début et puis après
c'était trop tard on le montre du doigt
il doit démissionner et il est là qui
ronge son frein journaliste l'a vu au
palais l'amirauté où il reste quelques
jours avant que son appartement
personnel soit prêt et dit j'avais
l'impression d'un lion engage ils
allaient et venaient toujours voûté
comme il l'a été toute sa vie dès sa
jeunesse ses têtes qui est déjà une tête
de bouledogue et puis il prend des
papiers sur son bureau et on l'entend
dire les dardanelles les dardanelles il
est obsédé
il est en pleine dépression
et alors il dit je suis officier je
demande à aller servir dans l'armée on
le lui accorde
on lui donne le grade de major le voilà
en flanc à ce book on lui fera commande
un bataillon il le commandera très très
bien
c'est un commandant dynamique courageux
efficace et voyez vous c'est important
ce séjour dans la boue des tranchées
parce que paradoxalement il y retrouve
sa sérénité qu'il avait fui totalement
et puis à londres ce dimanche on va pas
se priver éternellement de churchill
c'est un malheur d'homme c'est l'énergie
fait homme c'est une compétence
considérable il manque au gouvernement
non lui dis allez venez il va devenir
ministre de l'armement et alors là il
fait des prodiges il est fait aussi pour
ça parce qu'il faut armer cette armée
britannique l'armée américaine qui
arrive figurez vous que les soldats
américains arrivent sans armes
il n'y a pas d' usine d'armement aux
états unis il arrivait faut leur
procurer l'armement c'est la même chose
en france nous armons les américains qui
arrivent chez nous
[Musique]
on
et churchill sera l'homme des temps et
cela montre que ce conservateur est un
homme d'avenir
il a vu avant la guerre les premiers
temps manoeuvre et il en a déjà commandé
pour la marine et maintenant gland
commande par centaines on les jettera
dans la bataille et les obtiendront des
succès décisifs cette turquie
et puis s'occupe de l'aviation il a
compris que l'aviation s'était également
larmes de l'avenir et savez vous ce
qu'il fait ce ministre il se lève tôt à
8 heures il est au bureau il travaille
l'expédient la paperasse comme il dit
jusqu'à midi pourquoi bien parce que
l'après midi ils volent tous les jours
il part sur un avion survolait la manche
d'abord et puis ensuite les lignes de
l'autre côté de la manche
il veut se rendre compte par lui même
parce que les rapports il n'y croit pas
il veut voir et bien entendu avec les
avions de l'époque c'est un risque
quotidien
une fois son avion prend feu au milieu
de la manche une autre fois ils capotent
au moment où il va s'envoler la
troisième fois il le conduit le pilote
lui même et l'avion tombe comme une
pierre de 30 mètres sur l'aérodrome de
croydon et des débris surgit un ministre
qui va tranquillement se rendre à la
chambre des communes est prononcé deux
heures plus tard l'un de ses discours
les plus brillants saissac turquie et la
victoire disons le kili a pris une part
considérable
il est encore ministre après cette
victoire dans une coalition
travaillistes libéraux conservateurs
et il joue encore un rôle de premier
plan puisque c'est lui qui envoie un
corps expéditionnaire en russie accord
qui aurait pu jouer un rôle important
et c'est lui qui de toutes pièces de
concert avec le fameux lawrence d'arabie
le colonel lawrence va créer le royaume
d'irak et va mettre frère de faysal sur
le trône de transjordanie
[Musique]
il prépare l'avenir mais quand il veut
intervenir dans la guerre qui oppose la
grèce et la turquie alors en angleterre
cet atelier général tout de même
l'angleterre ne va pas se faire le
soldat du monde entier nous n'allons pas
récoltées sur nos épaules le poids de
toutes les guerres du monde ce mettez
vous à la place de ces gens qui viennent
de se battre dans une guerre terrible
ils n'ont pas envie de repartir et
l'incident est si grave parce que
churchill s'est engagé très loin que la
coalition qui est au pouvoir depuis si
longtemps
libéraux et conservateurs et clape il y
à de nouvelles élections et churchill
perd les élections
il vient de se faire opérer de
l'appendicite et déclare ben voila je
n'ai plus de postes je n'ai plus de
sièges
je n'ai plus de responsabilités je n'ai
plus dabadie ce qu'est ce qui me reste
il ne reste plus rien que lui-même chat
yeux alors puisqu'il est renvoyé chez
lui et bien il écrit car n'oublions
jamais l'écrivain tiens ça n'est pas un
écrivain d'occasions c'est un écrivain
qui fait de la politique ou un
politicien qui fait de la littérature
mais les deux disciplines sont toujours
étroitement liés dans sa vie il va
écrire l'histoire de la crise mondiale
c'est-à-dire les quatre années de guerre
c'est un admirable lio avec un style à
la fois lyrique et précis intégrant
style anglais et classique
il est fait pour écrire à la manière
classique tchatcher
et il va gagner une fortune avec celui
c'est grâce à cette formule qui valent
acheté un manoir le manoir de chartwell
où il va vivre désormais chaque fois
qu'il le pourra avec sa femme et ses
enfants
[Musique]
et
il est très adroit de ses mains on va le
voir sans cesse avec une truelle avec du
mort qu'il refait le toit
et puis alors il est dans le jardin il
s'occupe lui-même de son jardin et puis
il écrit d'autres livres et il obtient
de grands succès et puis tu n'aimes il a
bien envie de retourner de retourner à
la chambre des communes
or il est obsédé depuis un certain temps
par la montée des travaillistes
autrement dit les socialistes n'y a pas
doute que peu à peu les travaillistes
prennent la place des libéraux or
capsule éprouve une véritable feuille
pour le nouveau régime qui s'est
installée depuis 1917 en russie
pour lui lénine est l'homme à abattre
les communistes sont d'abominables
criminel qui n'est pas les communistes
et or l'a pas une espèce de
simplification qui lui ressemble bien et
qui est d'ailleurs fort tu as juste il
mêle les socialistes et les bolcheviks
qui n'ont pas grand chose à voir il faut
bien le dire alors il se dit il faut
faire un rempart contre les
travaillistes contre nos bolchevique à
nous qui s'appelle de travaillistes elle
estime que le parti libéral auquel il
appartient toujours est incapable
d'établir se rend pas seuls les
conservateurs forment un parti à 6 lits
pour barrer la route aux travaillistes
autrement dit au bolchoï
donc il va quitter le parti libéral et
adhérer de nouveau au parti conservateur
ce qui sera aussi mal vu qu autrefois
encore un renégat encore la veste
retourner ben oui c'est ça tranquille
mais ils estiment que s'il le fait c'est
parce qu'il doit le faire
les intérêts particuliers qu'on lui
attribue facilement de ces faux c'est
parce que réellement il pense qu'il faut
devenir conservateur justement pour les
raisons que je viens de dire et quand
les conservateurs gagnerons les
élections et bien baldwin stanley
baldwin bon bourgeois anglais sans génie
une grande inintelligence souligné
baldwin l'appellera comme chancelier de
l'échiquier ce qui est le pire des
cadeaux qu'ils pouvaient lui faire car
tu cherches il n'est pas un financier
churchill n'est pas un économiste
parce que devant cette crise terrible
qui s'est répandue dans le monde entier
depuis ce fameux jeudi noir de wall
street
c'est crise économique qui s'abat sur
l'europe et notamment sur la grande
bretagne
eh bien tu cherches il est incapable d'y
faire face alors il va
des mesures qui sont les erreurs
tragiques le retour à l'étalon or erreur
tragique
la baisse des salaires erreur tragique
ce a déclenché des grèves immense
partout qui met littéralement
l'angleterre au bord du gouffre et
finalement on veut plus d'eux tu retires
il quitte le ministère
et il le quitte pour très longtemps
surtout il le quitte avec la réputation
d'un homme qui n'est plus dans le coup
et voyez vous c'est une chose terrible
sens politique en anglais c'est le cas
de parler anglais on pourrait dire has
been
et oui churchill c'était très bien
pendant la grande guerre mais mr voilà
voilà ce qu'on dit de lui même alors
c'est l'homme qui va rester député il
est réélu député mais qui n'a plus de
responsabilités ministérielles
c'est l'homme qui parle à la chambre des
communes mais qu'on écoute comme un
original
voilà c'est le mot carte il est devenu
un original un peu bougon bohu pauvres
surtout pour un homme qui a été si haut
et qui rend du temps de service la
situation qu'on vienne lui faire est
quelque chose de terrible d'accablant et
pourtant c'est celle qui sera la sienne
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
depuis qu'il est allé en depuis que il a
assisté aux premiers pas du nazisme
il sait dire qu'il parce que c'est
gigantesque homme d'état quoi qu'on dise
de lui il sait que le péril est là et
même la haine qu'ils avaient pour les
bolcheviks il l'a toujours mais enfin
ils ont les bolcheviks on n'en parle
plus pour le moment
l'ennemi numéro 1 c'est hitler c'est la
bête parce que lui qui est un but de
toutes les traditions démocratiques de
l'angleterre
il a vu que ce régime c'était la
négation des libertés la négation des
droits de l'homme alors ils parlent ils
s'inquiètent ils alertent il adjure il
dit mais voilà tant d'avions par mois
tant de chars d'assaut par mois et
ballerines vient dire maintenant notre
collègue monsieur churchill est mal
informé les chiffres sont beaucoup plus
bas les voilà les véritables chiffres
or ce sont les chiffres de churchill qui
sans vrai et pas du tout ceux de
monsieur baldwin et les années qui
passent
lui donnent raison
[Musique]
il est là non son manoir de chartwell il
voit quelques amis très rare
on invite plus nulle part parce que
voyez-vous le métier de cassan qui est
devenu le sien averti à dire attention
le danger approche
personne n'aime ça quand on veut se
faire cassandre on ne reçoit que des
coups on se fait que des ennemis
[Musique]
il va rencontrer dans le monde 2006
simpson cette américaine que le nouveau
roi edouard viii thème profondément et
il run algarade devant elle avec un
journaliste américain qu'il écrasera par
la force de sa dialectique et puis après
il dira mais c'est simpson vous êtes
étonné que ce lieu parler si longtemps
et si fort c'est voyez vous que je n'en
ai plus jamais l'occasion depuis le
début de l'année on m'invitait nulle
part alors c'est la première fois que je
sors bien j'en ai profité
ce même triste
alors il l'a découvert autre chose il
peut maintenant et chaque fois qu'il se
déplace il emporte son cheval et ses
pinceaux des toiles et ce sera sa grande
distraction jusqu'à sa mort peindre ce
n'est pas un peintre génial mais ça
n'est pas non plus un mauvais pâtre
surtout il a pris beaucoup de plaisir à
peindre surtout dans ces années là il
avait besoin de se détendre qui
n'auraient eu besoin à sa place de se
détendre les nerfs
[Musique]
et voilà que l'histoire lui donne raison
et voilà que hitler envahit l'autriche
et voilà qu hitler envahi la slovaquie
et que la guerre est à la porte
alors on commence tout de même à faire
un peu attention à ce que dit le vieux
de churchill qui entre temps a eu
l'élégance de se muer en paladin parce
que le roi est amoureux boire 8 est
amoureux de son américaine mais ce sims
à mener a déclaré qu'elle voulait
l'épouser et ça a été une immense lever
le bouclier contre lui l'establishment
la coucou les intérêts
et puis la politique baldwin qui
représente la vieille tradition l'église
baldwin elle achevait une joue l'un et
l'autre un rôle fort peu claire personne
le défunt edward ou ici alain quartier
et je dis franchement que c'est très
beau et que si nous devons aimer
churchill nous devons l'aimer aussi pour
cela n'a aucun intérêt à défendre le roi
au contraire et il le défend une fin un
disque aux admirables
il s'adresse aux travaillistes et il dit
vous ne défendez les gens qui sont
pauvres
les ouvriers les paysans vous réclamez
pour eux le droit au bonheur et je vous
comprend alors pourquoi voulez vous que
le roi notre roi n'est pas aussi le
droit au bonheur avec leurs beaverbrook
ils envisagent une solution
un mariage morganatique mais tout est
balayé par l'union sacrée des intérêts
de la haine parce que voyez-vous la
majorité des hommes qui ne sont
justement pas heureux n'aime pas
envisager qu'un autre justement soit
heures et il est sorti de la thur t-il
encore plus discrédité new york choc
olala pour que celle autrefois oui bah
oui mais qu'est ce qui les deux pauvres
est châtié et pourtant tout lui donnent
raison
voici que hitler à munich fait venir à
lui les puissances européennes
[Musique]
et voici que daladier pour la france
neville chamberlain pour l'angleterre
vont s'humilier à munich et quand ils
rentrent dans leurs capitales
respectives tremblant parce qu'il froid
qu'on va les injurier on les attrape
c'est ce qu'on a appelé le lâche
soulagement et cherchent ils alors
prononce un de ses plus beaux discours
il dit je vous comprends je ne vous
critiquent pas vous avez remercié ses
hommes de vous avoir évité la guerre
mais il faut que vous sachiez que ce
n'est que reculer pour mieux sauter que
demain la guerre sera prête vous alors
préparez vous je vous le demande
faites tourner vos usines fabriquent et
de l'armement
mobilisez vos armes et la guerre est là
et mondiaux menon à munich
c'est la paix qu'on nous a données pour
un demi siècle
onze mois plus tard l'histoire donne
raison à chuck et quand la guerre éclate
comme il l'avait prévu
neville chamberlain aussitôt l'appel au
ministère car malgré le discrédit
artificielle qui pèsent sur lui depuis
tant d'années tout le monde sait que
churchill est à lui seul un immense
capital pour l'angleterre et il est
premier lord de l'amirauté
et savez-vous le message qu'on va
envoyer sur tous les bateaux anglais sur
tous les bateaux britanniques qui vogue
sur toutes les mers du monde
simplement ces mots winston est de
retour bah oui il est de retour et déjà
il reprend cette marine en main et si
quelques mois plus tard l'évacuation du
corps expéditionnaire sera réussie à
dunkerque c'est parce que lui car qu'il
a pris les mesures nécessaires
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le 10 mai 1940 c'est la ruée des armées
allemand et le jour même neville
chamberlain qui s'est de lui-même les
palop une telle situation quitte le
gouvernement et le roi le même jour
nomme premier ministre winston catch
c'est sur les épaules de churchill que
la guerre tout entier va peser churchill
en 1940 c'est très exactement le
professeur d'énergie dont parlait barrès
professeur d'énergie parce que
l'angleterre a écouté bouleversé
churchill lui parler le lendemain de
dunkerque
ces britanniques qui sont effondrés qui
croient l'angleterre perdu et bien le
langage qu'il leur tient et le langage
de l'espoir elle le prend dont 1,6 à
nous comprendre
il verrait berne
hendry
[Musique]
mais
de plus
oui un peu
[Musique]
la place et le rôle en mer noire
la guinéenne
oh
[Musique]
la guerre ce sera car l'homme qui reste
seul dans la france le quitte
l'homme qui n'avait à opposer aux
colossalement que la fragilité
britannique et qui gagne une bataille
dans le ciel de londres de l'angleterre
à l'automne 2009 140 la luftwaffe de
göring battu par la rs capitale parce
que l'invasion de l'angleterre préparé
par hitler est remise
et pourtant dans l'année 1941 sera une
longue suite d'échecs pour l'angleterre
est le seul cet état dans son île qui
est seule en tragique mon seul devant
l'europe entièrement occupée par heatley
est tout de même un allié qui surgit et
c'est hitler qui donne cet allié à
l'angleterre en envahissant la russie
voilà churchill allié à staline qui va
rencontrer staline au il n'a pas changé
déteste le bolchevisme
il sait très bien ce que seront plus
tard les ambitions de staline tempe il
faut gagner la guerre et ils d'éclat
vous savez si hitler envahissait l'enfer
j'aurai des paroles fortes agréable à la
tribune de la chambre des communes pour
saluer le diable l'efficacité rien notre
allié qui lui est fourni par les
japonais quand ils bombardent pearl
harbor les états unis qui entre dans la
guerre et maintenant cette guerre qui
est mondiale et churchill qui est
l'unificateur y va de l'un à l'autre de
staline house belt roosevelt à staline
les grandes conférences sommet
casablanca téhéran plus tard yalta plus
tard potsdam il est là partout et les
dominions qui l'animent et aussi les
alliés les alliés exilés qui sont à
londres le général de gaulle
disons le franchement sans la volonté de
churchill le général de gaulle n'aurait
pas pu diriger la france libre et dieu
sait si churchill et bien il envoie avec
le général de gaulle vous connaissait sa
phrase célèbre on dit que chaque homme
porte sa croix b moi je porte ma croix
de lorraine mais il est là partout savez
vous que c'est churchill qui anime
personnellement il laisse aux autres
ministres une coalition travaillistes
conservateurs le soin de conduire les
affaires intérieures la guerre c'est lui
les ordres sont donnés directement par
lui aux armées de terre
merde mais c'est lui entièrement
quelle est la responsabilité de tous
alors il faut le voir à downing street
sa journée et puis pendant le week-end
aux tchèques as il se réveille à 8
heures le matin ils travaillent dans son
lit parce qu'il est vieux
le vieux churchill il fatigué mais il
tient il travaille dans son lit avec ses
secrétaires ses collaborateurs vers 11
heures une je lève il prend un bain
saby reçoit ses visiteurs et ils sont
nombreux de toutes sortes les rapports
qui s'accumulent les décisions à prendre
il déjeune après le déjeuner il fait la
sieste il a besoin de cette sieste il se
déshabille totalement se couche dans un
lit et comme il fait jour il est un
bandeau noir qu'il met sur ses yeux et
il se réveille frais et dispos il prend
un second bas il a besoin
et puis de nouveau les audiences les
décisions les conférences les réunions
jusqu'au soir un dîner auquel il
convient toujours des personnalités
importantes et après le dîner un film il
a une salle de projection personnelle et
il emmène ses invités voir ce film il a
une prédilection pour les marx brothers
et puis après le film est bien ils les
gardent prêt lui jusqu'à 2 ou 3 heures
du matin les autres tombe de sommeil pas
lui et il va se coucher demain ce sera
une nouvelle journée au service de
l'angleterre
et puis
ce seront les débarquements l'afrique du
nord la sicile italie
[Musique]
la décision du second front prise à
téhéran le débarquement du 6 juin 44 la
victoire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la dernière grande conférence de la
guerre la conférence victorieuse sera
tenue à paddy dame au voisinage de
berlanne ya plus de berlin mais au
voisinage de berlin est bien sûr trop
non pas roosevelt qui est mort quelques
semaines auparavant
metro man son successeur mais staline
churchill or on est en train de procéder
à des élections en afrique et à la table
de la conférence de potsdam un
télégramme est déposée devant leur fils
il vient de perdre les élections
et oui pour le récompenser d'avoir gagné
cette guerre où il avait été immense les
anglais viennent de le chasser du push
et c'est son vainqueur le majeur clément
attlee le travailliste qui va venir
s'asseoir à la place toute chaude qu'il
laisse à la table de la conférence de
potsdam et nous savons par son médecin
combien il sera apte par cet ingrat
ticket et dira bien voilà ma vie' fini
fallait bien qu'elle finisse un jour
savez vous mon cher docteur ce que j'ai
fait hier moi je me suis levé à l'heure
habituelle et vraiment je ne savais plus
quoi faire je me suis recouché à midi
voilà tout ça et bien fini bah oui le
penser mais le vieux lion a toujours des
dents et il le prouve
ils attaquent cruellement les
travaillistes au pouvoir et il dit par
exemple un jour il hier devant le 10
downing street s'est arrêté un taxi vide
monsieur akli on est descendu et c'est
le même vieux lion qui en 1946 dans une
université américaine devant le
président trop mal prononcera le
discours qui sera comme une explosion
dans le monde je dis moi charge'' le que
depuis la mer baltique jusqu'à
l'adriatique du haut en bas du nord au
sud de l'europe ce qui s'est abattue
c'est un gigantesque rideau de fait et
ils dénoncent l'occupation de ces villes
illustre est belle de cas reste budapest
prague varsovie belgrade
où la liberté est morte le rideau de fer
désormais ce sera la pierre de touche de
la politique mondiale en 1949
les journaux annoncent une légère
indisposition de monsieur chat chez en
fait ce qui l'a frappé c'est une
hémorragie cérébrale
il se rétablit d'ailleurs avec une
rapidité foudroyante te retrouve vite
l'usagé de la parole les usages de ses
membres mais l'alerté sérieuse et son
médecin l'ordre moral lui dit monsieur
chat il il faut que vous sachiez que
vous ne reviendrez jamais plus au
pouvoir ce serait imprudent pour vous
imprudents pour l'angleterre
mais voilà que les travaillistes perdre
les élections suivantes
et voilà qu'il est le chef de la
majorité est logiquement le roi me
demande d'exercer les fonctions le
premier ministre at-il oublié ce qu'on
lui avait dit en 1949
peut-être pas mais voyez vous il faut
croire que l'exercice de pouvoirs
distille des voluptés suprême puisque
quand on le propose à quel cas il ne le
refuse jamais il y a un alibi aussi que
les gens se servent à eux mêmes de bonne
foi ils se disent que ça lui ils peuvent
faire face à certaines choses que
personne ne peut les remplacer c'est ce
que s'est dit le vieux turquie lille a
repris le relais en 1953 nouvelle légère
indisposition 19 heures
la vérité nouvelle hémorragie cérébrale
dont il se rétablit un peu plus
lentement et voilà qui n'est peut-être
pas étranger au fait qu'après ses 80 ans
lire a présenté sa démission à la reine
[Musique]
oh
ce concept des sports
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans le marbre et madonna
à naryn de michael ballack mais bébé
peut guère dire moche de terre ont bien
les bleus n'ont l'air afghane ni
continuer à écrire l'histoire de la
seconde guerre mondiale et on l'a oublié
mais savez vous que pour ce lit on lui a
décerné le prix nobel de littérature et
le voilà maintenant entrer non pas dans
l'ombre un homme comme churchill n'entre
jamais dans l'ombre mais ce qui a
commencé pour lui c'est ce que son
médecin appelle un l'on gagne eh oui
pendant de nombreuses nombreuses
nombreuses années il va dire adieu au
peuple britannique
on le voit voyager emporter partout son
cheval et ses pinceaux ses toiles on le
voit accueilli par tout comme l'homme
d'état le plus glorieux de son siège
et son corps se fatiguent et pas
seulement son corps son esprit et pour
ses 90 ans le peuple londonien tout
entier s'est portée devant la maison de
tchatcher et il attend que paraisse ce
vieil homme recrue de gloire et il
attend et on voit enfin derrière la
fenêtre close une vieillesse las
silhouette soutenu par la vieille
crémone times clemi comme il l'appelle
comme il a toujours appelé et on
l'acclament mais le lendemain paraîtront
dans les journaux les photos prises en
gros plan et ce matin là le coeur de
plusieurs dizaines de millions de
britanniques et d'autres hommes et
d'autres femmes dans le monde
se servent parce qu'on pourra constater
que dans les yeux de winston churchill
il n'y a plus aucune vie au lendemain de
la guerre le roi lui avait proposé le
titre de duc
il avait refusé il était petit fils de
ducale est il crée un nouveau duché au
sein de son propre duché et puis mon
dieu seul avait plus d'alluré tonnes pas
vouloir être duc lui qui n'avait pas été
duc a préparé ses obsèques
minutieusement il a écrit le programme
le rituel de ses obsèques et ses
obsèques seront celles d'un roi
[Musique]
salué par la reine toute la famille
royale
les représentants de tous les peuples
étrangers l'angleterre toute entière
elle est là dans l'eau sa dépouille
mortelle ira vers sa dernière demeure
descendra sur une vedette sur la tamise
car il s'est souvenu de nelson nelson
aussi avait été portée par un bateaux
sur la tamise temps l'eau la mer sont à
séparable de l'idée même de la grande
bretagne
[Musique]
mais
et
la gare de waterloo et blaine âme
le château le domaine de sa famille
mannheim là où il était né et il
retourner au point de départ
la boucle était bouclée
[Musique]
je
adieu winston jack
il avait simplement oublié de demander
une épitaphe
mais l'histoire l'a choisi cette
épitaphe
elle est dans l'un de ses discours
fameux prononcée en 1940 au moment où
l'angleterre était seul contre tous
elles se résument en très peu de mots
nous ne nous rendrons jamais et
peut-être pourrait-on y ajouter ce qu'a
dit de lui charles de gaulle dans le
plus grand des drames il a été le plus
heureux
[Musique]